so you're a citizen of the soviet union
in the early to mid 1900s
you're just the average peasant that's
just trying to get by and live your life
in a country that's had a very chaotic
history recently
the russian revolution just happened in
1917 so now the soviet union was a thing
and you are now a comrade in this new
thing called communism
as it turns out turning over everything
farming agriculture manufacturing jobs
to a few greedy politicians thousands of
miles away
didn't work out so well which resulted
in multiple famines with plenty of
universal suffering to go around
so you're thinking to yourself well i'm
starving
i can't get my hands on any goods but
hey under communism everyone owned
everything
and if everyone owned everything then no
one really owns anything
and if no one owned anything then surely
i could just take the stuff i wanted
from others since they didn't own it
that wouldn't be considered theft now
would it so everyone quite literally
everyone stole what they could
many for survival many for their own
personal gain alright so you are thief
now and a bunch of people you know are
thieves too
and since it's pretty self-evident by
now that your comrades and the
government aren't gonna put food on the
table for you
and your new communist jobs aren't
cutting it well you might as well
partner with your fellow thieves to
steal more than you could steal on your
own
so that's what millions of people did
and this perfect storm of revolution
famine war suffering of the early to mid
1900s
resulted in an estimated 7 million gangs
around russia
and what did your comrades in the
government do you petty these are no
better than the greedy capitalists and
are therefore enemies of communism
so into the gulag you go the soviet
union's giant network of labor camps
that a shocking number of people in the
west don't really know much about
so the petty thieves were sent to the
gulags along with the more hardened
criminals
and any of the opposition to the people
in power and along with people who
disagree with the government
and pretty much everyone else too
[Music]
and it was in this network of labor
camps death camps that the russian mafia
was born
bred organized and homogenized and when
the volvo zagone
leaves in law or thief within the law
were released from the gulags
they would turn russia into the biggest
mafia state in the world the superpower
of crime
according to boris yetzen the first
president of modern day russia
this is the economics of the russian
mafia one of the most unique organized
crime groups in history that would give
the american mafia and the yakuza a run
for their money
but first we gotta thank our sponsor
look the holidays are coming up
everyone is taking it easy everyone
starts showing up a little late to work
slacking off
operating in this holiday mode hey papa
what did i do is it merry christmas or
what
but i'll let you in on a little secret
the successful people out there that are
making the money you want that have the
life that you want have already mapped
out their 2021
and they're using this opportunity to
get ahead while everyone else is caught
off guard
and guess what they don't have just
money goals all of them have health
goals
why because it's kind of hard to make
money if you're obese tired all the time
and you can't make smart decisions
this is where magic spoon comes in i
loved eating cereal as a kid
until i found out how disgustingly
unhealthy it was but with magic spoon
you get the exact same sugary
deliciousness
without the sugar with 11 grams of
protein and only three net carbs
it's so good that i finished multiple
boxes already with my favorite flavors
being coca which tastes like your
favorite chocolate cereal
and their fruity flavor you are already
gonna gain weight this holiday season
so why not just skip all that nonsense
and start 2021 strong
so in the spirit of that and for the
first time ever you can build your very
own variety box
pick from my favorite flavors to frosted
blueberry plus brand new flavors
including peanut butter and cinnamon
build your own custom box today by going
to magicspoon.com
jaketran and be sure to use promo code
jake trend to get free shipping at
checkout
magic spoon is so confident in their
product that is backed by a hundred
percent happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund you your money no
questions asked
pause the video right now and build your
own custom box at magicspoon.com
jake tran will code jake tran for free
shipping
[Music]
much like the american mafia and the
yakuza the russian mafia is very much a
byproduct of russia's history
but this is also what makes the russian
mafia also known as the warri or thieves
very different from other crime groups
for example la cosa nostra the italian
american mafia and the yakuza were both
extremely strict when it came to who
could join
for la costa nosha for the most part you
have to be italian or sicilian to get
into the inner circle
for the yakuza you have to be japanese
or you'll forever be considered an
outsider
we've done video essays on both that you
can check out by the way but the russian
mafia is a lot more progressive
inclusive compared to their mafia
counterparts because they were joined
together under the banner of being
against the government and authority
they welcomed all the ethnic groups that
came from the surrounding soviet states
states like armenia ukraine georgia
uzbekistan kazakhstan and more
with the main requirement being that
you're a hardened criminal who's been in
the gulak or prison multiple times
so if you're an sjw that cares about
diversity in the workplace
you should consider applying for the
russian mob the italian-american mafia
is well known for its rigid pyramid
structure
with a godfather at the top and under
boss below him captains under that that
managed the soldiers and associates who
run the mafia's day-to-day operations
like a healthy running corporation not
the russian mafia though
time and time again american cops would
try to fit the russian mob into a
pyramid shape only to find that there
was something completely different
russian organized crime was more of a
decentralized economy of criminals than
just a few big crime families
as we mentioned earlier russian
organized crime may not necessarily be
just russian it also may not be all that
organized either
and it grew to encompass more than just
crime with the central thing tying them
together being the distinctive way they
operate
it's not a gang it's a bunch of facebook
friends as one european cop put it
but at a street level they do have a
loose structure keep in mind
that these positions aren't always
official titles and vary there's the
pokken who's the boss of the gang
kind of like the godfather who controls
everything hey
papa the pocket typically controls a few
criminal cells
so you heard in person and you get these
boxes out of sight
each cell is made up of brattuck or
soldiers
beneath those soldiers are interns or
aaron boys looking to move at the ranks
called shishtorka
with a captain of the cell called
brigadier or brigader that reports to
the boss
but to really understand the russian mob
to really understand how they make money
their rackets how they got so big
how they got so deep in bed with the
russian government to where it becomes
hard to distinguish them apart
we have to go back in time
before the russian revolution and
communism in 1917
russia was ruled by monarchs kings that
they called zars
under the tsars there were already a
good amount of gangs but they weren't
nearly as powerful influential or
cohesive as they would grow to be
then came the revolution nothing in the
world is more powerful
than an idea whose time has come the
bolsheviks point the finger out the
greedy capitalist and the petty thieves
like we talked about earlier
they took power by force so the only way
they were able to maintain their power
was to rule with an iron fist
and to rule with an iron fist to climb
those ruthless ranks
you needed to have a more flexible sense
of morality
and by needing a flexible sense of
morality they attracted the not so petty
criminals to pursue profitable careers
in government
this was the very beginnings of russia's
long unholy alliance between organized
crime
and government again that perfect storm
of revolution famine war suffering led
to the explosion of 7 million gangs
around russia with all the crime that
came with it
and then came the gulags
[Music]
in the soviet union if you so much as
made a joke about stalin or the
government
that would be 10 years 25 years in the
gulag for you
by the end of it all estimates say
around 18 million people were imprisoned
in the soviet gulag system of forced
labor camps
giving a certain guy where a certain
small mustache a run for his money
but the thing you have to understand is
that gulags weren't just a tool to keep
criminals and political threats at bay
see if the soviet union were to beat the
evil americans
the government would need a lot of labor
so the government used gulags as both a
state building and economic tool
and as a psychological tool
the goal wasn't to just punish those
no-good criminals but rather to exploit
them economically
in the name of the collective good of
course and to transform them
psychologically
need a power plant a ditch dug move some
prisoners around and have them get to
work
so understandably criminals gang members
and the like that were already not fond
of the government for not providing for
them
only grew to hate society even more
while in prison
so they banded together helped each
other out stole and committed crimes
together
and just like how every war veteran
talks about how their teammates are like
brothers to them
because of the life and death
experiences they went through together
the extreme conditions of the gulags
cemented the bond between these
prisoners and arms
and as prisoners got moved around
different camps to relieve overcrowding
prevent prison fights
or to labor on new economic goals these
criminals within the law
intermingled exchange ideas tactics and
bonded and the thief culture this boring
gangster subculture spread
their signature tattoos emerge within
the prison walls in russian prisons
life story is written on your body in
tattoos
each with their own symbolic meaning
stars on his knees means he'd never
kneel before anyone
now if you're thinking that yakuza
tattoos look way better that's because
they do
but the vori had to make do with what
they had in soviet prisons
so don't be too hard on them with their
sworn code being that a true thief a
true war
never helps the government never enlists
as a soldier never helps the prison
guards
or in other words devori completely
reject legitimate society
and only operates in their own criminal
society and it really was an underground
society
they held their own course their own
trials all governed by their code of
thieves and honor
but this dedicated criminal culture
would soon change
[Music]
because there were so many prisoners
tons of innocents and a smaller
population of actual criminals
the guards needed help keeping everyone
under submission running a forced labor
camp is hard
and just like the government you needed
people with a flexible sense of morality
to help out these poor prison guards
the good news is that this is a prison
you already have a bunch of tough
hardened criminals at your disposal
so what did the guards do they enlisted
the war's most capable mafia members to
keep their political and petty criminals
productive
the more traditionalist gangsters that
didn't believe in helping the guards
weren't a fan of these criminals
so there was a gang war between the two
factions the guards helped the side that
helped them and they won the war
and this new generation of gang members
would further cement the collaboration
between the government
and the thieves and when the gulags were
disbanded around 1960
these collaborator criminals would be
set free to plunder the soviet union
they got their training in prison and
now it was time to take on the state and
[Music]
economy
while all of this was happening the
soviet economy was suffering as usual
so a new breed emerged to supplement the
soviet economy black market
entrepreneurs
secret underground capitalists that
smuggled goods into the country and sold
them among other things
since these black market barons operated
outside of the government
they couldn't just call the police or
sue if something went wrong
so who did they hire the gangsters the
gangsters were offered protection to
these entrepreneurs
for a price of course and over time they
got to see how the secret capitalists
worked
how they lived and they came to see that
they could do that too the more they
collaborated with the entrepreneurs the
more they learned about entrepreneurship
the more they collaborated with the
state the more they learned about
politics
which would set them up for their next
evolution the violent entrepreneurs
as they developed their business acumen
these gangsters saw a huge gap in the
marketplace
courts were extremely corrupt back then
even if you didn't get cheated by the
judge enforcing a judge's rule wasn't
easy
and you can forget about the court
system if you're a black market
entrepreneur
see one of the main purposes of
government is to protect people's
private property and to settle disputes
he owes me money he stole from me he
signed a contract saying he would do
this but he didn't
and when the government fails to provide
the service people will naturally turn
to other service providers that will
so the gangsters came in and created
what's called enforcement partnerships
where gangs will offer business owners
the protection the government failed to
give them
you couldn't be sure if the government
will follow through to protect you but
you can be pretty sure that these
gangsters will use any amount of
violence they
need to earn that 50 of the dispute in
question
to build their reputation to build their
brand name as the best enforcers
or in other words these russian
gangsters learn how to monetize their
violence
to become the violent entrepreneurs the
honest criminals
this culture of working with honest
criminals was quickly interwoven into
the very fabric of society the economy
and politics
and then came the fault of the soviet
union from 1988 to 1991
which shot the thieves into the
stratosphere
[Music]
russia was in complete turmoil in every
regard during the 1990s
laws were being rewritten on the fly so
they were confusing and contradicted
each other
policing courts were stretched then
russia's stock bond and currency markets
collapsed the currency was hyperinflated
by 2 500 percent
a third of russians were living in
poverty by 1999 it was
a mess so the government was in
desperate need of money to pull them out
so what did they do they started selling
the state's assets which included
everything the government owned
shops restaurants small businesses large
businesses supplies raw materials make
29 fighter jets for 23 million dollars
which would later be known as the
privatization of russia
and who was ready cash in hand to buy
these assets
well it definitely wasn't the average
comrade being that it took a month's
wage to buy a tire the state was
auctioning off
no it was the corrupt officials insiders
black market entrepreneurs that would
later be known as the russian oligarchs
and of course the russian mafia who were
rolling in cash from their previous
violent entrepreneurship
and the lines between politics business
and crime grew hazier and hazier as
russian organized crime played a key
role in the country's next evolution
and with all this newfound territory and
opportunities the russian mafia spent
the 90s violently expanding and sinking
its grip into society
this was a decade of drive by shoe
readings car bombs and the virtual death
of whole industries
and in 1994 president yetsen declared
that russia was the biggest mafia state
in the world
[Music]
once putin took over and became the
president of russia he took back the
government's monopoly on violence
and is widely credited for taming the
russian mafia but that's not the whole
picture
see putin had ties to organized crime
when he was working as the deputy mayor
of st
petersburg by now the gangs had already
established their boundaries after the
90s
they knew that putin was the real deal
and that more violence would be bad for
business
so the claim is that there's an unspoken
contract a hidden deal between the state
and the mafia that as long as they don't
cause a public disturbance
as long as they're discreet as long as
they settle scores and assassinations in
private
and as long as they cut government
officials in on the action the
government
won't bother them sure there will be
some arrests here and there but nothing
major
i am not in russia so i can't comment on
if this is still the case myself but
that is the claim
in 2010 elite claimed that bribery alone
totals an estimated 300 billion dollars
a year
and much like the yakuza the romantic
image of the hardened tattooed gulag
russian gangster continues to live on
but in practice today's russian mafia
are more of criminal businessmen
economic gangsters that span places like
eastern europe spain new york
and are involved in everything from
petty theft to billion dollar money
laundering
to legal businesses and investments as
well
so you know the bowl of cereal that i
poured in the beginning of the video
well i finished it so we are gonna have
some more just for you guys
and because it's really good not as much
this time just a little
get that nice cereal asmr for you guys
yes
now that is out of the way another video
that you guys have been requesting a lot
lately
on the russian mafia so i hope you guys
enjoyed it the russian mafia is not
so well known as like the yakuza or
uh the italian american mafia so
information for this one was a little
bit harder to find
as you can see we are in a new set today
i think this microphone is slowly
dragging down
we're gonna work with that so we're in a
new set and you would have known about
this new set
if you follow me on instagram at
jaytrend.io where we post
behind the scenes stuff day in the life
kind of stuff memes cool quotes that i
share and find when i like study and
read stuff so yeah don't miss
out jaketrend.io if you want to support
the channel financially of course we
have our sponsor magic spoon
which i very much enjoy eating this is
the blueberry flavor
i don't think i like it as much as the
chocolate and fruity flavor but it's
still very good
i'm very excited to try their new
flavors though especially cinnamon
because i
really really like cinnamon and you can
get your custom variety pack at
magicspoon.comtran
with coupon code jaketran for free
shipping
supporting the channel financially so if
you enjoyed it make sure you click that
like button
and make sure you subscribe for more
video essays just like this one every
single week
on the most provocative stuff in the
world of business of course if you want
uh video notifications for when new
videos come out you can either click the
bell icon below
or you can sign up for our email
notification list
down in the description below because
sometimes the bell doesn't work
if you're new to this channel and you
want more crime videos like this
we do videos on like crime power money
business
wow all right this is really sagging and
we've already done one on the yakuza and
the mafia
so you can check that out with the cars
at the end of this video
or in the video description below that
is gonna wrap it up thank you so much
for sitting through all these shameless
plugs you've been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you